yeah jump in what we were talking about
divulging personal information about
yourself to to somehow increase the
appeal of your brand yeah I think that
that's fine I'm afraid is 1 meter brand
this ooh I like it I'll take it I think
as long as it's not if as long as it's
not real long is not true people can
know anything they want to know about me
you know explain that sentence well if
it makes you it makes someone feel like
they like me better because they because
they know that I can just want to say
something like the live at you like Joey
Krenzel womanizer nothing you're not a
wonder I wonder what you would want you
on your camera I want to be a derogatory
but if someone said like Oh Joely eats
like french toast every morning you know
and that's not true but if that make
someone like me more and they go go rent
my movie then that's fine if they need
they want but I think it's much more
likely the people are going to have sort
of it was those sort of salacious kind
of details about you are much more
appealing well I think that it was going
to get wrecked well that's true or not
yeah but that's an out of my control you
i mean if people feel like they need to
know that information about but would
you ever do you get a cell like if you
felt if you're your publicist was like
Joe if you come forward and you confess
your drug problem or marital
infidelities whatever that's what people
are going to love you for that then in
your right yeah yeah i gotta agree with
that i think doing else to do that if
they should I think Terrence Malick does
it well I think in terms of people who
handle their career and publicity wise I
think Terrence Malick zuzu this does a
wonderful job what is normally man well
because he doesn't feel to me that
doesn't see me feels an obligation to go
out and
I feel like he doesn't feel an
obligation to good to go out and promote
and make appearances and divulge
personal details about himself but still
I knew his name and you know his manager
everybody here knows his name very very
popular guy he I mean in terms of you
know in his career makes you know movies
get works with great people has a lot of
money for his films his films make a
decent amount of money he seems to sort
sidestep that machine the publicity
machine all together and it doesn't seem
to hurt him at all I think it's also i
agree with you and I think it's very
detrimental for an actor but for people
to know too much about them personally
because we play characters you know and
every character we play we bring a
little bit of ourselves to you have to
but if someone knows too much about me
they won't be able to watch me on film
and say hello I'm losing myself that's
that character you know sometimes and I
think he's great actor with Tom Cruise I
watched Tom Cruise now and I don't know
if necessarily watch the akera Kerr that
is playing you know because I know too
much about his personal life and it's
interesting me today it's a danger that
I guess can happen to any actor if you
become famous enough in this era
anyone's going to want to know personal
things about you but it's very difficult
to keep those things close to the chest
anyway I think it's detrimental to actor
their career it's like when you're
watching your friend we have a lot of
friends that are actors and when you're
watching them sometimes it's hard to
lose yourself and see them do you know
them to what to really lose your side to
make it secretary yet totally agree yeah
you just always want to call
yeah because you look you're not a tough
guy yeah look at you pointing a gun ya
know what you're doing what everyone
around you is like I watched it on
that's terrible yeah
you